joining me now the man fighting for it
Georgia Senate candidate Herschel Walker
Herschel great to see you tonight
now what should the priority be for GOP
leadership Mitch McConnell seems to want
to cut deals with Chuck Schumer
um and conservatives out there are
saying wait a second you know what about
the principles we care about
well you know I think some of the first
thing you should think about is the
reason I decided to run is we the people
not we the government and that's the
problem we have that's one reason I
decided to run had nothing else I just
saw that the Georgia people I saw the
people of the United States for being
mistreated they're spending our money
when we don't have any money they made
us unsafe by giving up all the energy
then right now there's border wide open
and you hear Chuck Schumer talking
already about bringing more people in
well we got to secure this border right
now Fenton is killing a lot of our young
people from 18 to 45 and I think you
need new leadership we need new
leadership all the way around that's the
reason I said when I'm going to when I'm
going to Washington I'm going as a
leader because I represent the people of
Georgia that's all I don't care about
anything else and then right now the
people of Georgia and the people of the
United States need representation in
Washington
now your opponent uh Warnock is warning
that something very fishy is afoot about
the looming runoff watch this
I've had to stand up time and time again
when we've seen efforts at the federal
level
and at the state level
to make it difficult for people to use
their voices some of the most
suppressive parts of SB 202
apply to the runoff
being held in the state of Georgia right
now
Herschel are these uh conspiracy
theories
well first of all you know he's he's
continued to try to separate and divide
SB 202 will pass a long time ago he's
known about it so don't try to train
change the rules in the middle of the
game right now we're in a runoff so do
your job get out and see your people
that's what I'm doing I'm getting out to
try to get the people to get behind me
because we need new leadership he's went
to Washington and he's represented no
one but Joe Biden he went to Washington
he's forgot about the Georgia people
that's the reason I decided to run but
right now he's trying to divide again
with racism that everyone is being
mistreated well first of all let's try
to bring some Integrity bike to this
election uh system right now I'm upset
people couldn't even count votes we can
get that straight but at this time right
here the rules have already set so let's
not try to change them what we do is we
do what we have on the books then you go
and you try to change it do not throw it
on the people this has nothing to do
with the people this had to do with the
leaders that have put we put in
Washington and we put a week later with
senator what not in Washington to do
nothing but go with Joe Biden or go with
what they're telling him to do when
Herschel Walker is not that man that's
the reason I encourage everybody all the
time I said they're trying to buy this
seat go to teamherzer.com you will see a
fighter I'm a fighter I have nothing in
this in this fight except my family and
that's the people of the United States
of America that's the Georgia people and
that's what I'm going to Washington due
to Washington to do is to fight for
those people there
Herschel great to see you tonight as
always thanks so much and good luck hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else